هذا الطريق الذي ياخذنا الى احدى الغابات
التي اشتعلت فيها السنه اللهب خارج
العاصمه اوتاوا التي لا يزال هواؤها ملوث
بسبب دخان الحرائق من المواد الخضراء اللي
موجوده
بالحرائق الغابات هو غاز اول اكسيد
الكربون وهو غاز سريع الانتشار جدا
وعديم الرائحه ولذلك يعني عندما يستنشقون
الناس
فيحصل اغماء بالبدايه واذا كانت كميه
كبيره تحصل وفاه التاثير لم يختصر على
الجانب الصحي فقط بل اثر اقتصاديا ايضا
فمثلا ارتفعت اسعار الوقود في المناطق
القريبه من الحرائق وصلنا الى منطقه
سنتياليكا التي تبعد ما يقارب 160 كلم عن
العاصمه في مقاطعه انتريو وصلنا هذه
النقطه ولم يسمح لنا بالعبور وذلك بسبب
الحرائق التي تلتهم الغابات في هذه
المنطقه والتي من اكبر الحرائق فيها في
هذه المنطقه ايضا انقطعت الاتصالات
وانقطعت اشاره الانترنت المنطقه شبه خاليه
من السكان بسبب عمليات الاجلاء منازل
فارغه وطرق بدت خاليه تم اجلاء السكان
منها ومن لا يزالون يعيشون ولو بعيدا عن
الحرائق سيطر الخوف عليهم من وصولها اليهم
نحن خائفون لا نعلم متى تاتي الحرائق
الحكومه تحاول مكافحه الحرائق لكن هناك
جفاف وارتفاع بدرجات الحراره الجفاف بدا
واضحا في هذه المناطق المحيطه بالغابات
المشتعله التي تشهد اكثر من خمسين حريقا
34 منها خارج السيطره لوثت المياه
والطبيعه رفع السعد العربيه اوتاوا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات